[Applaudissements]
gilles respect font comme il ya quelque
chose
les nommés qui s'attend lui c'est pas
une balle non mais je vous jure qu'il se
passe un truc de ouf la machine je vous
jure c'est vrai il est en négatif mais
oui vous avez le guen est paré avec
choses en sont arrivées il ya quelque
chose en vous il ya du césium 137
ah oui il ya du radium et encore pire
ils recrutent omnium elle est encadrée
par machine
mais oui mais oui c'est vrai mais bien
sûr ce que ces trois éléments mais avec
votre machine vous trouvez un gilet
bâtiment des charlots ils ont des tas de
charlot mais évidemment oui il est trois
éléments au mois mais comment grâce à
patrick molis j'ai pris de la terre
radioactifs
ah oui c'est vrai j'ai dû être
décontaminés et en angleterre pour qu'on
voit si j'étais positif
il y avait un mec qui était là et c'est
il disait que c'était son terrain et lui
il est arrivé il a pris il a fait ses
matchs
non parce que bien mais plus que les
hommes d'un suivi du bal on fait quand
même 27 millions je sais que j'ai ça
pour 20 alors oui c'est grave vous avez
des délires comme ça dans ma vie
si le sujet est maigre parle atrabilaire
j'ai d'autres entités
j'ai de très grosses quantités et des
sceaux curé est noble et des ceintures
et les saturer mado si nous sature
je propose qu'on fasse quelque chose
juste après la mi temps